Hello, hello. Happy Friday, everyone. We are getting really close to the premiere of the paper. Yeah, it's next week. It's Thursday, September 4th. And then our breakdown of the pilot comes out September 10th. I know. Ah! There is no special episode next Friday because we assume you're all going to be busy watching the paper. Yes. So today we have two interviews for you. The first one is with Ramona Young. You might know her from Mindy Kaling's show Never Have I Ever. She played Eleanor or maybe on D.C.'s Legends of Tomorrow. And you know, we've been sharing in these interviews how during our set visit, we were just grabbing people as they became available. Well, within like seven minutes of talking to Ramona, a production assistant came over and pulled her back to set. I know. And she's so lovely. She shared some fun tidbits. But because our interview with her was cut so short, we thought that,
哈喽，哈喽。大家周五快乐。我们离《The Paper》的首播真的越来越近了。对，就是下周。也就是9月4日，星期四。然后我们对试播集的剖析将在9月10日发布。我懂。啊！下周五没有特别节目，因为我们猜大家都会忙着看《The Paper》。没错。所以今天我们为大家准备了两个采访。第一个采访对象是雷蒙娜·杨（Ramona Young）。大家可能通过明迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）的剧集《好想做一次》（Never Have I Ever）认识她。她在里面饰演埃莉诺（Eleanor），或者你可能在DC的《明日传奇》（Legends of Tomorrow）里见过她。你知道的，我们在这些采访中分享过，在我们探班期间，我们基本上是抓住任何有空的人就进行采访。嗯，在跟雷蒙娜聊了大约七分钟后，一个制片助理走过来把她拉回片场了。我知道。而且她人太好了。她分享了一些有趣的趣事。但因为我们对她的采访被剪得太短了，所以我们觉得，
after the break, you could hear the interview we did with Bemisola Ikumelo, who was both a writer and an actor on the show. She was also a writer and actor on the TV series, a league of their own. Yes, carrying on the tradition of having writer performers on a Greg Daniels show. Yeah. You know, we'll have even more to share about that when we get to our full breakdown of the paper. But let's jump in. Here are your interviews with Ramona Young and Bimisola Ikemello. Ramona, thank you so much for talking to office ladies today about your role on the paper. Can you tell us your character's name and who she is in the world of the show? Yes, I like that you're holding the microphone like a reporter.
休息过后，大家可以收听我们对比米索拉·伊库梅洛（Bimisola Ikumelo）的采访，她在剧中既是编剧又是演员。她也是电视剧《红粉联盟》（A League of Their Own）的编剧兼演员。没错，这也延续了在格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）的剧中启用编剧兼演员的传统。对。你知道的，等我们对《The Paper》进行全面剖析时，会有更多这方面的内容与大家分享。但我们现在就开始吧。以下是你们听到的对雷蒙娜·杨和比米索拉·伊库梅洛的采访。雷蒙娜，非常感谢今天做客《Office Ladies》，跟我们聊聊你在《The Paper》中的角色。你能告诉我们你角色的名字，以及她在剧中的世界里是谁吗？对，我喜欢你像记者一样拿着话筒的样子。
Yeah, so my character's name is Nicole Lee. She works in circulation. So basically that means she mass emails people who are signed up and she keeps subscriptions going. How did you get your job on the paper? We always like to hear people's like origin stories. I sent it was a long process. It took like several months. And so it felt like a really big deal and it is.
对，所以我的角色叫妮可·李（Nicole Lee）。她在发行部门工作。所以基本上这意味着她向那些注册过的人群发电子邮件，并维持订阅量的持续。你是怎么得到《The Paper》这份工作的？我们总是喜欢听听大家的背景故事。我记得这是一个很长的过程。花了大概好几个月。所以感觉这是一件非常大的事，事实也确实如此。
But I started off with a self-tape. And then I did like a like a like a. like a sit down. Did you guys have that too? Like a sit down with just like Greg and and I sat down with Greg and Michael and we just like talked for like over an hour about my life and I didn't know what to expect. I was just told to show up. This is very Greg. You know, Kelly Cantley, who's one of the first ADs on the show, was also first AD on the office. And her interview when she shares about when she interviewed with Greg was they talked for like an hour and he just asked her about her hobbies and and that she likes to sail and didn't ask her
但我一开始是自己录试镜视频。然后我进行了一次那种……那种……面谈。你们也有这个吗？就是跟……只跟格雷格……我跟格雷格和迈克尔坐在一起，我们就这样聊了一个多小时关于我生活的事，我根本不知道会发生什么。我只是被告知要出现。这非常“格雷格”。你知道的，凯莉·坎特利（Kelly Cantley），剧组的第一副导演之一，也是《办公室》（The Office）的第一副导演。她在分享自己面试格雷格时的经历时说，他们聊了一个多小时，格雷格只问了她的爱好，问她喜欢航海，却一点也没有问
at all about being an AD. But I think he likes to get to know the essence of a person so he can see if he can be like a creative collaborator with that person. Yeah. I mean, I think there's there's so much about, like, building a community when you're making a show. And I think Greg is really cognizant of that. And so I think he's looking for people who inspire him, you know? And so I think that's part of his process. It's weird, though, right? Because as an actor, you think it's just all about the audition. Right. Like, I'm used to just kind of like showing up and doing my job. But I do feel like this is one of the first projects where I feel like, oh, this is like really personal and they do want to like, you know, they do want me to like share
关于做副导演的事。但我觉得他喜欢了解一个人的本质，这样他就能看出自己能否与这个人成为创作上的合作伙伴。对。我的意思是，我觉得制作一部剧时，很大一部分工作都在于建立一个社区。而且我觉得格雷格对此真的很有意识。所以我觉得他在寻找能给他带来灵感的人，你知道吗？所以我觉得这是他流程的一部分。不过这很奇怪，对吧？因为作为演员，你会觉得这一切都只是关于试镜。对吧？就像，我习惯了只是那种露面然后做好我的工作。但我确实觉得这是我参与的第一个这样的项目，让我觉得，哦，这真的很私人，而且他们确实希望……你知道的，他们确实希望我能分享
ideas. And if I want, I can like reach out. Like I, you know, like I never felt really comfortable or as comfortable doing that in the past. But I feel like on this show, it's kind of like a necessity. Yeah, we felt that too. We were able to pitch storylines or ideas that we had. And some of them ended up being episodes. And when we both left the office, we learned pretty quickly that is not the norm on a set. Yeah. Are there any character traits or storylines that you've pitched so far that have made it into the episodes? Storylines, no.
想法。如果我想的话，我可以联系他们。就像我，你知道的，我以前从未真正感到舒适，或者像现在这样感到自在。但我觉得在这部剧里，这有点像是一种必需品。是的，我们也有同感。我们能够提出我们想到的故事线或创意。其中一些最终还真的成了剧集。当我们俩离开《办公室》时，我们很快就了解到，这在片场并不是常态。是的，到目前为止，你有没有提出过任何进入剧集的角色特质或故事线？故事线，没有。
I don't know if I've actually like pitched anything just because I love seeing what the writers come up with. But I do like journaling a lot. And so I'll journal like what I think Nicole's been through in her life and stuff so that maybe it'll inspire something for. other people to write. You know what I mean? Oh, I do. I had a whole Pam document and her whole backstory were things that I invented. And every once in a while over those nine years, some little thing that was in my journal, my backstory, would find its way into the show. Just little
我不知道自己是不是真的“提出”过什么，因为我太喜欢看编剧们想出的点子了。但我确实很喜欢写日记。所以我会把我认为妮可一生中经历过的事情等等写进日记里，这样也许能为其他人写作提供一些灵感。你知道我的意思吗？噢，我懂。我曾经有一整本关于帕姆（Pam）的文档，她的整个背景故事都是我凭空捏造的。在那九年的时间里，每隔一段时间，我日记或背景故事中的某个小细节就会悄悄进入剧集中。只是一些微小的
bitty details. So keep it up. Yeah, it makes a difference. Sometimes I'm like, oh, I hope I'm not like overstepping, but they kind of make it feel really welcomed. No, I knew my character really well. I still know exactly how she would react in any moment. In fact, we were watching a scene with Oscar, and I was like, oh, I know exactly how Angela Martin would react in this moment. I could just walk right on that stage. So it's really fun to know your character that well, because then you can play.
细节。所以坚持下去吧。是的，这确实会有所不同。有时候我想，哦，希望我没有越界，但他们总是让人感到非常受欢迎。不，我真的很了解我的角色。我依然确切地知道她在任何时刻会有什么反应。事实上，当我们看奥斯卡（Oscar）的一个场景时，我在想，哦，我太知道安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）在这种时刻会有什么反应了。我可以直接走上那个舞台。所以，对自己的角色有这么深入的了解真的很有趣，因为这样你就可以尽情发挥了。
Whatever they throw your way, you know what she's going to say. We would love to ask you about your journey in your career. and like how it started and what your background was sort of like how you got to where you are today. Yeah, I guess I started off just kind of like everyone else.
无论他们抛给你什么，你都知道她会说什么。我们很想问问你的职业生涯历程，它是怎么开始的，你的背景是怎样的，以及你是如何走到今天的。是的，我想我一开始也是像其他人一样。
I started making a profile on Actors Access back when I was a teenager and did a lot of background work and YouTube shorts and booked my first co-star and did that. And I don't know if you know this, Angela, but we've worked together like three times.
我还是个青少年的时候就在 Actors Access 上创建了个人资料，做了很多群演工作、YouTube短片，然后接到了我的第一个联合主演角色并完成了它。安吉拉，我不知道你知不知道，我们其实一起合作过大约三次。
Oh my God. We've never had any scenes together, but we were on three projects together where I watched you do scenes, which is really creepy to say. I... Hi. Oh, no.
天哪。我们从来没有过任何对手戏，但我们曾一起参与过三个项目，我在现场看着你演戏，这么说听起来真的很诡异。我……嗨。哦，不。
Okay, can she finish this one thing? Yeah, yeah. Okay, so I will fess up and say that we were on the real O'Neils together. We were on a Netflix show that I was then recast in, but I showed up for that week together. And we were... What show? I forget the title.
好吧，能让她把这话说完吗？行，行。好吧，那我就坦白吧，我们一起拍过《The Real O'Neils》。我们还一起拍过一部Netflix的剧，后来我被换角了，但我在那拍了一周。我们还……什么剧？我忘了名字了。
It was like Miranda. Haters back off? Yes. Yeah. Yeah, I was there. And we also did Never Have I Ever together. Never have I ever, yes. I mean, I have a very small cameo in that.
好像是《玛丽亚》。《松手吧，恨意》（Haters Back Off）？对。对，我在那儿。而且我们还一起拍过《好想做一次》。《好想做一次》，对。我的意思是，我在里面只有一个非常小的客串。
You're great. I have, like, I'm barely in it. But that, wow. So, you know what this means? we're meant to finally be in a scene together. Someday, me and you are going to have a scene together. We're just putting it out into the world. I really hope so.
你演得很好。我基本上……我几乎没怎么出场。但那，哇。所以，你知道这意味着什么吗？我们命中注定最终要一起拍一场对手戏。总有一天，我和你要有一场对手戏。我们只是把它说出来让全世界听到。我真的希望如此。
That would be great. Yeah. Well, thank you so much for your time. We hope we get to talk to you again. We know you have to go to work now, but thanks for making the time for us. Thanks. And I just want to say, like, I love the original office cast so much. And you guys seem so intelligent and thoughtful.
那太棒了。好的，非常感谢你抽出时间。我们希望还能有机会和你聊天。我们知道你现在得去工作了，但谢谢你为我们腾出时间。谢谢。而且我只想说，我真的很喜欢原版《办公室》的演员阵容。你们看起来都太聪明、太有思想了。
And that was one of the things that made me really excited about this project was how great everyone was. Thank you so much. This is an ad by BetterHelp. You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal, do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, what helps you get through the day? helps you get through stressful moments. Mm-hmm. For me, it's talking it out.
这也是让我对这个项目感到非常兴奋的原因之一，那就是每个人的表现都太棒了。非常感谢。这是一则来自 BetterHelp 的广告。你知道，感觉现在不管什么事都有人给你出谋划策。比如，你写日记吗？你做过，我不知道，排毒、冷水浴，还是说，什么能帮你度过这一天？什么能帮你度过压力的时刻？嗯。对我和来说，是把事情说出来。
Mm-hmm. Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true and what actions to take these days. So you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through BetterHelp. It has an app store rating of 4.9 out of 5 based on over 1.7 million client reviews. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies.
嗯。关于心理健康和健康养生，可能会有大量的信息过载，如今要想知道什么是真理、该采取什么行动，可能会是一场挣扎。所以你可以考虑使用一个值得信赖的资源，通过 BetterHelp 与在线治疗师进行交流。它在应用商店的评分高达 4.9 分（满分 5 分），这基于超过 170 万客户的评价。作为全球最大的在线治疗服务提供商，BetterHelp 可以为你对接拥有各种专业知识的心理健康专家。通过 BetterHelp 把心事说出来。我们的听众在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 首月可享 10% 的折扣。
That's BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. With Amex Platinum, access to exclusive Amex pre-sale tickets can score you a spot trackside. So being a fan for life turns into the trip of a lifetime. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Pre-sale tickets for future events subject to availability and vary by race. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at amex.ca.com.
网址是 BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com 井号 office ladies。使用 Amex Platinum，尊享独家美国运通预售门票，让你直击赛场前沿。让一生的热爱，化作一生的难忘之旅。这就是 Amex 的强大后盾。未来活动的预售门票视供应情况而定，且因赛事而异。适用条款和条件。详情请访问 amex.ca.com。
This episode is brought to you by Defender. With its 626 horsepower twin-turbo V8 engine, the Defender Octa is taking on the Dakar rally. The ultimate off-road challenge. Learn more at landrover.ca. Hello, hello. Hello. Could you please tell us your name and your character name?
本集由 Defender 赞助播出。Defender Octa 搭载 626 马力的双涡轮增压 V8 发动机，正在征战达喀尔拉力赛。终极越野挑战。了解更多信息，请访问 landrover.ca。哈喽，哈喽。你好。能请教一下你的名字和你的角色名吗？
My name is Bimisala Ikumelo, and I play Adelola Aloffin. Or as you guys may say, Adelola Alofen. And will you tell us what your character's story is on the show, who she is to the world? Yeah. I mean, I think Adelola is. She's an accountant, so she works under Oscar and she works with Adam and I think she's been there for a while. And I think her whole aim in life is just to get through the day, have as little interaction with humans as possible and get home and get under the covers and sleep and generally sort of build up enough money so that she can move out of the place that she lives with with her brother. and his fiancé.
我叫比米索拉·伊库梅洛（Bimisola Ikumelo），我饰演阿德洛拉·阿洛芬（Adelola Aloffin）。或者你们可能会叫她阿德洛拉·阿洛芬（Adelola Alofen）。你能跟我们讲讲你的角色在剧中的故事吗，她在剧中是个什么样的人？好的。我的意思是，我觉得阿德洛拉是……她是一名会计，所以她在奥斯卡手下工作，也和亚当（Adam）一起工作，我觉得她在那儿工作有一段时间了。而且我认为她人生唯一的宏伟目标就是熬过这一天，尽量少跟人类互动，回家钻进被窝睡觉，然后总的来说攒够足够的钱，好让她能搬出那个她和她哥哥
That's kind of the story I have in my mind for her. Yeah. I love that. We both knew our characters very well and kind of had our own backstories. We would love to know a little bit about your audition process and how you came to be on the show.
以及哥哥的未婚夫一起合住的地方。
Yeah. I mean, it was just like, it's just like any other day. I got a sort of a tape sort of come through a sort of self-tape for a top secret show. And they was like, we can't tell you what it is. And it was just, and it was obviously sort of dummy script.
这就是我在脑海中为她构思的故事。是的。我太喜欢了。我们俩当时都对自己的角色非常了解，并且都有各自的背景故事。我们很想了解一下你的试镜过程，以及你是如何加入这部剧的。
And there was sort of lines in there that were said talking head stuff. And I started going sort of stroking my whiskers going, could it be? Could it be? But I didn't want to assume anything. But yeah, so I just sort of did a lot of tapes for a random character whose name I don't even remember anymore. And then my agent after that was like, yeah, Gregory liked the tape. And we can confirm it is for a show that's going to be set in the office universe. I was like, okay. And then I met with Greg and with Komen via Zoom, because I was in the UK. And he was just like, yeah,
是的。我的意思是，这就好像……这就像平常任何一天一样。我收到了一份……通过电子邮件发来的试镜带，是一个绝密节目的自我试镜。他们说，我们不能告诉你这是什么。然后它显然是一个……虚构的剧本。
we loved it. And talking a little bit about what this is going to be. Because it, I mean, even the scripts didn't, weren't what they were. So it is all, we have no idea where we're going with this story, with this character. So it's all sort of just trusting the genius that is, you know, the other of the creatives on this show. And then, and then we started bringing up writing, because you're a writer, right? And I said, yeah, yeah, I wrote on another US show. I was in the writer's room for another US show called League of Their Own. And he was like, oh, great.
里面有一些谈话访谈类的台词。我当时开始摸着胡须心想，会是它吗？会是它吗？但我不想妄加猜测。不过是的，我只是为这个甚至连名字都不记得了的随机角色录了很多试镜视频。然后在那之后，我的经纪人打电话来说，是的，格雷格很喜欢这个试镜带。我们可以确认这确实是一部设定在《办公室》宇宙中的剧集。我说，好吧。然后我通过 Zoom 与格雷格和科曼（Komen）见了面，因为当时我在英国。他当时就说，
And I said, I'd love to, you know, be in the room if that's an option. He was like, yeah, yeah, yeah, let's look at that. And the next thing I knew, I was in the room and in the cast. So it kind of, yeah, it happened really quickly, you know, yeah. So you're one of our crossovers. You are both a writer and an actor on the show. I am one of the crossovers. I am both a writer and an actor in the show, yeah.
我们太喜欢了。并稍微聊了一下这个项目将会是什么样的。因为这……我的意思是，甚至连剧本都不是最终播出的那样。所以这一切，我们完全不知道这个故事、这个角色最终会走向何方。所以这在很大程度上只是去信任天才般的编剧——也就是剧中的其他创意人员。然后，然后我们开始聊到写作，因为你是个作家，对吧？我说，对，对，我曾为另一部美剧写过剧本。我曾为另一部名为《红粉联盟》（League of Their Own）的美剧的编剧室工作过。他听了就说，哦，太棒了。
So is that something? I'm sorry. No, you go, you go. Is that something you've ever done before where you've done both on the same project? Yes. So with Liga their own, it was the same thing. I'd auditioned as an actor and when they were put in the room together
然后我说，如果可以的话，我很乐意加入……你知道的，加入编剧室。他当时就说，行，行，行，我们考虑一下。接下来我知道的，就是我既进了编剧室又成了演员。所以它差不多……是的，发生得非常快，你知道的，是的。所以你也是我们的“双栖跨界者”之一。你既是剧中的编剧，又是演员。我是“双栖跨界者”之一。我既是剧中的编剧，又是演员，是的。
I just went, hi, I'm also a writer and I would love to be considered and they considered me and it was such an amazing experience and that was sort of in the height of COVID and everyone was so it was very remote it was the first sort of remote writer's room thing that I'd done
所以这是你以前做过的事吗？就是在同一个项目里兼顾这两者？是的。所以对于《红粉联盟》，情况也是一样的。我作为演员去试镜，当他们把编剧室的人聚在一起时，
that was for Liga their own and it was kind of as it was a similar vibe with this because I, for the first 40% of the room room, I was in the UK zooming in, and then in the summer I flew out and joined the room in person. So, yeah. Okay, well, I'm very curious, where do they have you seated in the world of the show?
我只是走过去说，嗨，我其实也是个编剧，我很希望能被考虑一下。他们真的考虑了我，那是一次非常棒的经历。那正值新冠疫情最严重的时候，每个人都在……所以非常远程。那是我做过的第一个远程编剧室的工作，
You're right in the middle of the bullpen, right? They don't have you tucked away somewhere so you can sneak off to the writer's room. God, I actually, in hindsight, I'm like, yeah, we should have tucked me away somewhere because I'm, yeah, I'm there all the time. There were days, I'm like, oh, I just, I just, I just sit here and then the shot and just type away, cool, got it, got it. But, yeah, so there's no sneaky, there's no sneaky offy. I'm right there. But not in the middle.
也就是为了《红粉联盟》那次。而且这次的氛围也有点类似，因为我，在编剧室工作的前40%的时间里，我都是在英国通过 Zoom 连线参与的，到了夏天我才飞过去，亲自加入了实体编剧室。所以，是的。好吧，我非常好奇，他们在剧中的世界里把你安排在哪里落座？
It's a very, it's a very, much a bigger kind of office than the office. And so there's sort of lots of, there's a very few staff for the space that it is, you know, which is, I think, an interesting commentary on where we are with journalism, you know. So, yeah, so we're in the encounter's corner of the room. But yeah, we are definitely in that, the middle of that space. Right. You're not back in the annex. That's where they put Paul and Mindy.
你就在大办公区的正中央，对吧？他们没有把你塞到什么偏僻的小角落里，好让你能溜去编剧室吧？天哪，事后回想起来，我在想，对啊，他们本来应该把我塞到某个角落里藏起来的，因为我……是的，我整天都在那儿。有时候我会想，哦，我只是……我只是坐在这里，然后镜头扫过来，敲打键盘，酷，搞定，搞定。但是，是的，所以没有什么悄悄溜走的说法。我就在那儿。但不在正中间。
They were way back there. How much input did you get to have into your character's look, into your hair, makeup, wardrobe? Sabrina talked a little bit about how maybe she had some ideas about how her character dressed. And I'm just curious, we had a lot of input on the office. So how has that been here? actually really great it was actually really interesting because she went on a very interesting
这是一个……比《办公室》要大得多的办公室。所以在这个空间里，员工其实相对很少，你知道的，我认为这对于我们当今新闻业的现状来说是一个有趣的讽刺。所以，是的，所以我们坐在房间的会计角落里。不过是的，我们绝对是在那个空间的中央。没错。你没有被塞回 annex（偏安一隅的副办公室）。那是他们放保罗（Paul）和明迪（Mindy）的地方。
journey the character and I think Greg was and Coleman were really great at sort of letting me figure her out and kind of go in a little bit of a different direction and I sort of woke up one day
他们被塞得老远了。对于你的角色的造型、发型、妆容以及服装，你有多少发言权？萨布丽娜（Sabrina）之前稍微聊过，她对自己的角色该如何穿衣有一些自己的想法。我很好奇，我们在《办公室》里有很大的发言权。所以这里的情况是怎样的？其实真的很棒。其实非常有趣，因为这个角色经历了一段非常奇妙的
and I said I think she I wanted to feel more a bit weirdo burnout vibes just I wanted to feel a little bit less professional like she sometimes hasn't figured out what she's going to wear and she's running late for work and she just you know effortlessly picks out the most clashy clothes but she's not doing it on purpose she's just like these will do and i'd sort of put a character bible together as well so i'd sort of nerded out a bit and because i really was trying to it was a little bit it's
旅程。我觉得格雷格和科曼真的很好，他们让我自己去琢磨她，并朝着稍微有些不同的方向发展。我记得我有一天醒来时，
a bit of a challenge when you're you've got other characters in your head as a writer that you're pitching for and, you know, to actually spend time with just Adelola and figuring out who she is. So I had to go away and just go, who is she for me? And so I did this big old document and with images of what she looked like and what, you know, where she, where she studied, where she was born. And so when I gave that reference to Grecky was like, yeah, that look, let's do that. And to the wardrobe department's like credit, they turn that whole new look around in like a 24-hour period and the next day came in and she was just it was just color it was vibrant septum rings and you know and things like that so um so no i was really so i did get some input in there but the
我说我觉得她……我希望她能呈现出更多一点“怪咖倦怠感”的氛围。我只是想让她看起来没那么职业化——就像她有时候还没想好今天该穿什么，上班要迟到了，然后顺手……毫不费力地挑出色彩撞得最厉害的衣服，但她又不是故意的，她只是觉得“这套就行了”。而且我还写了一份角色圣经（Character Bible），所以我也花心思做了一番极客式的深入研究。因为我真的在努力……当你作为一个编剧，脑子里装着其他你要为之出谋划策的角色时，要去花时间专门陪伴阿德洛拉并弄清楚她是谁，其实是一个不小的挑战。所以我必须抽离出来，独自思考：对我来说她究竟是谁？于是我做了厚厚的一份文档，里面有她外貌的参考图片，以及她曾在哪里学习、在哪里出生的背景。所以当我把这些参考资料交给格雷格时，他说：“行，就这个造型，我们这么干。”值得服装部门称赞的是，他们竟然在短短 24 小时内就把这套全新的造型给做出来了。第二天她一走进片场，就全是色彩，充满活力，戴着鼻中隔环，还有诸如此类的东西。所以……不，我真的很……所以我在那上面确实有一些发言权，但团队把这些想法落地，并以一种真正与众不同的方式升华了我脑海中的构想。这简直是我们的最爱。这是我们的最爱——我们超级喜欢深入了解你的角色，了解他们的背景故事，而且你竟然还做了类似角色圣经的东西，我们简直太喜欢了。我们特别喜欢回过头去看《办公室》里的角色，去读他们的剧集圣经。这真的太酷了。我太喜欢你这么做了。作为演员，我并不总是会为角色这样做，但对这个角色而言，感觉就像是……而且，你知道的，我觉得有些角色会随着故事的发展而不断成长。特别是在《办公室》里，有些角色一开始戏份很少，后来却成了粉丝的最爱，他们不断成长，最终变成了
team turned that around in such a and elevated what was in my head in a you know really different way this is our favorite thing this is our we love investing in getting to know your character and what's their backstory and the fact that you did a character like bible that's we just love it We love going back and looking at the characters from the office and reading their show Bible. It's just so cool. I love that you did that. I don't always do that for characters as an actor, but for this one, it was just like, and, you know, I think there's, you know, there are some characters that are, that kind of, you know, will grow as a story gets along. So, and especially in the office as well, it was just characters that suddenly, you know, they had smaller parts and then they became fan favorites and they sort of grew and they, you know, became.
那种极具标志性的经典角色。还有一些角色，可能只是某个他们做过的某个造型，观众就非常喜欢。所以在对待阿德洛拉时，我不认为她总是……你知道的，她并不总是说很多话。吸引人的总是那种神情，总是她对周围视觉空间发生的事情的个人解读。所以为此，我觉得我需要比平时更加了解她的内心世界，因为事实上，也许她……她脑子里发生的事情，比她说出口的话要多得多。所以这，是的，让我觉得非常必要。她没有说出口的话往往表达了更多，是的。
sort of really iconic and some characters are just like it'd be a look that they do that would that the audiences loved and so with Adelola I don't think she's right you know she doesn't always say much it's always that sort of look and it's always the sort of her interpretation of what's going visually what's going on in the space around her but so for that I felt like I needed to know what her inner life was even more than I would normally because actually maybe she, it's a lot of what's going on in her head rather than what she says. So that was, yeah, it felt really necessary for me. What she's not saying says more, yeah.
是的，而且她是如何通过翻白眼、吸一口气等细节来表达“没有说出口的话”的，那究竟是什么样子的。所以，了解她的内心世界，了解她下班后要回到哪里去，她是从哪里来的，以及人们对她的期望是什么，这对我都非常有帮助。所以……在你的背景故事里，她和她的哥哥住在一起，她和她的哥哥以及他的未婚夫住在一起，而这两个人竟然同名，她觉得这超级烦人。这就是你创造出来的背景故事，我太喜欢了。格雷格同意这个设定吗？我的意思是，这……这随时都可以拿来用。谁知道以后会发生什么，说不定以后剧情发展会用到这个呢，但
Yeah, and how she's not saying it with like a roll of the eyes and, you know, and an inhale of breath and, you know, what that is. And yeah, so it was really good for me to know what her inner life was and what she's going back home to and where she's come from and what the expectations of her are. so I can yeah so in your backstory she lives with her brother she lives with her brother and and his fiancee who both have the same first name and she finds it really annoying this is what you've created I love it has Greg signed on to that I mean this is I mean it's there it's there for the taking who knows with that you know that'll happen down the line but
但不管怎样，这……是的，我太喜欢了。我知道……我丈夫那边的家族里，他表亲的名字叫科瑞（Corey），是个女孩，科瑞嫁了一个也叫科瑞的男人。所以他们是科瑞和科瑞。是的，我有点……是的，在我的脑海里——我不确定现在能不能说出来，万一以后剧情真的用了呢——但在我的脑海里，他们叫博拉（Bola）和巴拉（Bala）。一个巴拉的拼写带有一个 GB，另一个则带有 B。这就是他们的名字。你的角色是英国人还是……她是美国人？我们能听听你的美国口音吗？
but yeah that's um yeah I love that you know I My husband on his side of the family, his cousin's name is Corey, girl, Corey, married a man named Corey. So they're Corey and Corey. Yeah, I kind of, yeah, in my mind, I'm not sure if I should say if it ends up getting used, but in my mind, they're Bola and Bala. And one Bala is spelled with a GB and one is with a B. And that's those are their names. Is your character British or is she, she's American? Can we hear your American accent?
哦，天哪，别让我用美国口音说话，求你了。但是，说实话，我在片场必须全程都这样说话。否则，你知道的，大家就会开始让我觉得自己很英国。所以，每当我一开口说话，梅尔文（Melvin），哦，天哪，小号，低音号。然后就变成：老兄，我做不到。早安啊，长官。全都是这些无厘头的废话。全都是这些。
Oh, God, don't make me talk in an American accent, please. But, like, literally, I have to just talk like this the whole time on set. Otherwise, like, people start making me feel British. So, like, every time I open my mouth, melvin the blah, oh, my God, trumpet, clumpet. And it's like, dude, I can't. Top of the morning, too, you, governor. It's all that nonsense. It's all of that.
就像是：司康饼，这到底是什么鬼，老兄？所以我……我有点分不清自己到底还在不在用这个口音，有时候会不知不觉地在口音里切换。我突然就会用那种口音说话。然后我就想，哦，天哪，我怎么又成这样了。我刚才都没意识到。所以，是的，这太疯狂了。我以前在伦敦拍过一部剧。我拍过一部叫《你、我和世界末日》（You, Me and the Apocalypse）的剧。
It's like, scones, what in it, blood? So I've, I sort of, and I don't know that I'm doing it anymore, that I'm sort of slipping in and out of the accent. I'll just suddenly start talking like that. And then I'm like, oh, God, I'm here. I didn't realize. So, yeah, it's, that's so wild. I worked on a show over in London. I did a show called You, Me, and the Apocalypse.
它播了一季。剧里的三个美国人是梅根·莫拉莉（Megan Mullally）、我和罗伯·洛（Rob Lowe），除此之外全都是英国演员。我还记得当我到片场工作时发生的一件事，我要了一杯咖啡。大约15分钟后，端上来的是一个马克杯装的单杯法压壶咖啡。那是如此的文雅。我简直对这杯咖啡垂涎三尺。然后到了下午4点左右，剧组的餐饮服务（craft services）会端来茶水和饼干，一整套精致的茶具配上小饼干。当时我想，哦，天哪，这是真的，他们下午4点真的会停下来喝茶吃饼干，这太美妙了。当你来到美国工作时，反方向有什么让你觉得古怪的地方吗？你觉得我们的古怪之处是什么？哦，不，你们的剧组茶点区（crafty）简直夸张到像开挂了一样。你们还在那说什么精美的小点心和饼干。你们那儿有各种各样的甜甜圈，然后还有热食茶点区。就像是热食茶点区。我在想，我们不是快要吃晚饭了吗？不，但那儿还有热食茶点区。
It ran for one season. The three Americans in the show were Megan Malawi, me and Rob Lowe, and then otherwise a fully British cast. And one of the things that I remember when I would get to work, I asked for a cup of coffee. And it was like 15 minutes later, a single cup of like French press coffee in a mug. And it was so civilized. And I coveted this cup of coffee. And then around 4 o'clock, the craft services would, bring in tea and biscuits like a whole tea setup and little biscuit cookies and i thought oh my gosh it's
有那种泡菜碗和意大利面。我们在午饭前一小时还吃了拉面。然后还有热狗、百吉饼、果汁，冰箱里还有各种小意大利面沙拉。吃的东西简直没完没了。然后显然还有爆米花、
real they really they really stop for tea and biscuits at 4 pm this is wonderful what are some of the quirks coming the other way as you've come to america to work what are you tell us our quirks oh no your crafty is like is like on steroids it's like you talk about little quaint cuts and then cut and then little biscuits. You guys have donuts on donuts and then there's and then there's like hot crafty. They're like hot crafty. I'm like, aren't we about to have dinner? No, but there's also hot crafty.
坚果、这个那个的。所以这感觉就像是走进了一家街角小店，比如……或者像是一个……
There's like the kimchi bowls and pasta. We had ramen noodles like an hour before lunch. And then there's like hot dogs and and and and bagels and juice and and then little like pasta salad. of things in the fridge it's endless and then obviously then the just the popcorn
一个……哦，一家小型杂货店（bodega）。就像走进了一家 bodega，而且里面的所有东西都不用付钱，
and the nuts and the this and the that so it is like going into a corner shop like a or call it like a
并且你经常会看到我直接在那儿“购物”——到了周末的时候，我就会想：好吧，我要把这些拿回家或者放进我的化妆车里。另外，你们拥有最棒的餐饮服务商，因为你们有塞尔吉奥（Sergio），我们以前拍《办公室》时也有他。
a a um oh the a bodega a bodega yeah going into like a bodega and not having to pay for any of the stuff in there
如果你还没尝过他做的自制莎莎酱（salsa），那一定要试试，那是他岳母的秘方。那是我吃过最棒的莎莎酱。我多年来一直说：“你需要把这个莎莎酱拿去卖。”而他总是说：“不，这太耗时了。我们根本赚不到利润。”所以你们在这个片场拥有的是最顶级中的最顶级。不，这里的食物太惊人了。我第一天拍戏时还拍了个视频，当时仅仅是牛排，
and just and you'll see me often just taking shopping for the like at the end of the week I just like well I'll just take that for the week home or for my trailer. Also, you have the best caterer because you have Sergio, who we also had.
每个人都会问：“你想把牛排做几分熟？”当时我就想：我想要几分熟？他们居然可以按需现场制作牛排。这简直太疯狂了。这里的食物太棒了，就像……是的，简直太疯狂了。而且我每次来美国拍戏都是这样，到处都是这么多的食物。这本是一件美好的事，但对于像我这种面对食物永远不会说“不”的人来说，
And if you haven't tried his homemade salsa yet, it's his mother-in-law's recipe. It is the best salsa I've ever had. I have years have said, you need to sell this salsa. And he goes, no, it takes too long to make it. We couldn't turn a profit. So you have the best of the best on this set. No, food is amazing. The first day I did a sort of video of it when it was just steak.
这大概就是我骨子里的非洲血统在作祟吧，觉得拒绝食物很不礼貌。而且我见不得食物浪费。所以我哪怕已经吃饱了，也会变成一个“人类垃圾桶”。我会想：哦，天哪，我还能继续吃。所以这其实不太好。你刚才又不由自主地切换成美式口音了。这真的不太好。我甚至都没意识到自己又这样了。
and everyone would like, how would you like your steak? I was like, how would I like my steak? They were making steak to order. I was this just, it was, it was insane. The food is amazing, like on, like, yeah, it's just crazy. And I, every time I come to America and film here, it's, it's the same thing. It's just so much food. And it's a beautiful thing, but for someone like me who never says no to food,
好吧，非常感谢你今天跟我们聊天。这太棒了。我们祝愿你在剧中取得巨大成功。等不及想看了。对，谢谢，谢谢。非常感谢。你太可爱了。
like it's the African in me, it's like it's rude. And I can't waste food. So I become like a human dumpster, even when I'm full. I'm like, oh, God, I'll keep eating. And so it's not good. You just slipped into American. It's not good. I don't even know that I'm doing it anymore.
安吉，我很遗憾我们探班时没能采访到梅尔文，因为他真的太棒了。他是我最喜欢的配角之一。是的，我们在片场确实遇到了他，但我们当时没有对他进行真正的采访。现在我已经刷到第四集了，我更想看到他更多的戏份。他演得太好了。他真的把我逗笑了。是的。我很喜欢他的角色在事情发生时的那种反应。
Well, thank you so much for talking with us. This was amazing. We are wishing you much success on the show. Can't wait to see it. Yes. Thank you, thank you. Thank you so much. You're so lovely.
另外，我真不敢相信雷蒙娜和我曾经差点就同框了。我感觉——祈祷吧，雷蒙娜，这次幸运女神站在我们这边。好吧，也许在《The Paper》第二季吧。别把它说出去。到时候会有人发文写我们在拍第二季了。不过我也很喜欢比米索拉对她角色的服装有那么高的参与度，这让我想起了明迪。凯莉（Kelly）这个角色最初的设定是一个扣得严严实实、领口极高、非常保守的形象，是明迪慢慢改变了她。我就是挺喜欢这一点的。比米索拉从一开始就直接表示：不，我要立刻解开她的扣子。从一开始就这样。哦，还有她为自己角色设计的背景故事——她的角色
Andge, I'm bummed that we didn't get to interview Melvin during our visit because he is so great. He is one of my favorite supporting characters. Yeah, we did get to meet him on the set, but we didn't get an actual interview with him. And now that I'm four episodes in, I want to see more of his character. He's so good. And he really makes me laugh. Yeah. I love his character's take on things as they happen.
和她哥哥以及哥哥的未婚夫住在一起，而且他们名字还一模一样。这个设定细节实在是太丰富了。我知道。我觉得这绝对是那种以后会在某集里出现的桥段。我希望如此。我觉得这太爆笑了。我真的很喜欢她提到自己在片场时会一直保持美国口音的那段经历。当她突然又变回一口地道的英国腔时，她的搭档们一定觉得太疯狂了吧。我在想多纳尔·格里森（Donald Gleeson）是不是也会一直保持美国口音呢？是的。不知道。这个问题留到下次再问吧。好吧，各位，谢谢大家陪伴我们度过过去的几个星期五。这真的非常有趣。是的。再次感谢格雷格邀请我们去片场探班。我们下周三将带来关于菲利斯·拉平（Phyllis Lapin）的全部内容，然后是在9月10日发布我们对《The Paper》试播集的剖析。
Also, I can't believe how many times Ramona and I have always. almost shared the screen together. I feel like fingers crossed, Ramona, the odds are in our favor here. Well, maybe in season two of the paper. Don't put it out there. Someone's going to write it up that we're in season two. Well, I also love how much input Bimasola had in her character's wardrobe because it reminded me a little bit of Mindy how the first instinct for the character of Kelly was for her to be this buttoned up, like high neckline conservative character that Mindy slowly transformed her. I just kind of like it. That like Bimisola was like, no. From the beginning. I'm unbuttoning her immediately and from the beginning. Oh, and also her backstory for her character, that her character
到时见。到时见。感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》是 Audacy 的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubico）。Audacy 的执行制片人是莉娅·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《Office Ladies》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）进行混音和母带制作。
lives with her brother and her brother's fiance and they have the same names. It was so, so detailed. I know. I feel like that is something that would totally make it into an episode. someday. I hope it does. I thought it was hilarious. I really loved her story of how she usually stays in her American accent while she's on set. It must be so wild for her castmates when she is suddenly very British. I wondered if Donald Gleeson stays in his American accent, too. Yeah. I don't know. A question for next time. Yeah. Okay, everyone, thank you for joining us these past few Fridays. This has been a lot of fun. Yeah. Thanks again to Greg for inviting us to the set for that visit. We will be back next Wednesday with All About Phyllis Lapin, and then on September 10th, with our breakdown of the pilot of the paper.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Ruppertry》。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。
See you then. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
回头见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audacy推出的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audacy的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期节目由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertry》。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。